and so who who actually wants a  tournament so is it madness i'll have to  play magnus again right  yes so that was my next question daniel  because magnus carlsen is the winner of  the preliminary so it is  you against magnus again in the  quarterfinals  what will that be like  i mean for me it will be great fun as  always i mean i he  he's still my favorite opponent so i'm  obviously very happy to play him again  so it's once again the same story i mean  i repeat the same thing i don't care  about the result playing magnus  he's human and blah blah blah but in  general would still uh yeah i mean still  remains correct i mean i like to play  him very much so i'm very happy to play  him again obviously  fantastic